Have you heard the theory of the cat distribution system,
there is a theory that says that kittens are not from our eh of our planet
of this plane and that those kittens also have a mission which I really
believe because where cats come they sweep everything away and where cats
come they conquer my love I have a theory even that when they started to
chase cats and create this bad reputation of cats they are not from our planet.
cats eh there were other species that were against cats for this very
reason because when they arrive it is believed that they become Kings and
Queens then the theory says that every human being at some point in his
life will appear a cat and that cats are really not you who choose them
but it is the cat that chooses you the cat practically knows and has a mission.
that is why there are many people who have found cats in the strangest
possible circumstances and this is supposedly thanks to the cat
distribution system what do you think of this theory I think it has a
little bit of truth because that is those who have a cat and are parents
of cats like me know how intelligent these animals
are and more than all intuitive.